alright guys so let's get ready for this
dance-off I need three volunteers from
three different sections you're not
dancing you can't do Shelly
okay okay Shelly I need you to rate
yourself as a dancer from 1 to 10 hold
on
one being Elaine from Seinfeld and and
10 being you know black Michael Jackson
7 okay okay and now what I need from you
is one word to describe your dance style
athletic sultry hot just one word one
single word to describe your dance style
I'm not gonna lie to you I just got a
little tingly in my nono spot oh I
forgot to mention the first rule no
touching me all right I didn't make that
rule one night and it got [ __ ] really
weird is the name of your best dance
move [ __ ] that's part of everything I
guess all right thank you this is Shelly
she's 7 the dance style is everything
and her best move is [ __ ] awesome I'm
not gonna lie to you Shelly I'm
intrigued you said enough but not a lot
you know what I mean because everything
gets my mind racing and so does awesome
you know listen everybody I don't know
if you guys know we have a celebrity
here Jacques Cousteau's son is here and
um here for us today and I'm so nice to
see you man so jacques cousteau so let
me ask you something when they're not
calling you Jacque what are they calling
you what's your name
Tyler there you go okay
see you name's Tyler Tyler one through
seven let me ask you just relax how are
you nervous I would say like for a
nervous we're at a 10 4 out of 10
nervous yeah well you're not really
making it listen man nobody's out there
going well I can't wait to see this
[ __ ] guy dance didn't he just tell me
he was bored so so buddy you gonna you
gonna be able to get it up a little
oh you had five beers and a shot and
herpes oh and her beer oh yeah yeah you
sit in her beer be has hit it kind of
quick in a way and I was like oh aunt
herpes well alright those glasses are
yours uh her beers
but listen so you guys are going out I'm
so glad you have it on camera him
calling you herpes listen I would just
keep playing that back right around your
birthday like where are we going this
weekend your herpes your herpes all
right so your ass the whole time there
you go just like that
so tell me on a your for nervous which
is not bad and I'm it like a somewhere
around there what 1 through 10 tell me
how are you dancer that's not the
question I got to do is just answer okay
you're an 8 right now an 8 yo let me
just say some bold move
bold move because listen I always tell
people shoot low cuz if you're like a 4
and then you come out as I see you say
forward you come out of the 6 people are
like yeah ok he said for he six but you
came out 8 right now right now well
you're dancing right now [ __ ] so
they better be ain't right now and to
the herpes is clouding his memory I
think tell me one word to describe your
dance style aggressive now I'm and now
everybody's looking forward to see
urine-y oh you're an aggressive 8 that
sounds like a nickname at a gay bar yeah
how you doing I'm an aggressive eight
well I'm his dance move is herpes the
herp might be better do the herp I think
the herp is what we're gonna go with
what is your name Jen Jen how are you
tonight Jen show me again what it's like
to have not to show me that again yeah
okay it's not that far off you know but
yeah now I know you don't have nuts
listen guys which ones lower which one
yeah yeah yeah and those aren't the
scales of justice you know what I'm
saying that pretty much stays here Jen
so tell me one through ten one through
ten where you at as a dancer I like it
Jen's a five with those big balls
she was peeking big balls and then she
was like five okay here we go
okay this is there's gonna be a special
one I think guys Jen who was a five to
meet one word to describe your dance
style that's the is that your dance
style or is that your dance move
that's your dance move so what's your
dance style is it sexy so is it smooth
is survival that is
all right so that's Jen who was a five
her dance style is survival and her best
dance move is the thrust hey Jen Jen
don't keep away all your trade secrets
right now girl you are my fire the one
desire
when I say I won't eat that way you are
my fire the one desire believe when I
say you are my fire the one desire
believe whoa when I say it that way
[Music]
hey man wait when you said you were
gonna show us everything you were
reliant and where were your dollar bills
bro show some respect
this is not easy I will be the
tiebreaker if I have to but I hope I
don't have to because I wasn't paying
attention
going through this round are gonna beat
Jen and Tyler you are my fire the one
feyza
here believe when I say
[Music]
waiver we hunt tubers if I I can't
breathe through yo ha ha when I say I
wanted that hey and tell me why tell me
why he hotel me lie here I wanna die
I'm gonna say this for them as fellow
artists let me say this for them don't
you dare steal any of their [ __ ]
moves what you saw up here tonight is
copy written that was the herps and I
think you saw a couple of [ __ ]
thrusts if I if I'm not mistaken she has
birthed four children she she has done
her signature move over and over for you
people she has played after the whistle
can't stop won't stop Jen everybody
[Applause]
I want to say one thing real quick to
get up here and did what he did when he
was nervous nervous guys do you know
what you feel like you're doing when you
do when you're nervous you feel like
[ __ ] hiding into the table instead he
stood up on this [ __ ] stage he
basically put his penis on my knee he
was going for the little you know that
little under the leg hump you know that
[ __ ] thing working if I'm telling you
right now I don't know if he had the
best moves but he showed you the most
I'll tell you that right now
never stop moving did a little bit of
that James Brown listen guys let me hear
it for wait a second Jacques Cousteau's
Jacques Cousteau son the Irishman
the man even when he goes back and
leaves you know he's always gonna rear
his little red ugly face no man who
comes off harp no one other than Tyler
Wow man that's a tough call that's a
tough one man here's what we're gonna do
just to be just to be even-steven we're
gonna give both of them $100 and you
guys go sit out
[Music]
you